my first question for you is just how
are you we haven't talked in your life's
changed a lot I know uh no longer with
Joe but I'm doing a lot better with it I
mean it's hard because of course you
missed the person that you thought
you're potentially gonna marry but he's
doing really well
and so I'm happy for him yeah it was a
little bit of a surprise but I think
ultimately Joe foresaw his happiness and
work in Chicago and I I can't resent him
because of that and for me I just never
foresaw a future there so you know I
think it became an ultimatum within
itself where either we I'm to Chicago or
we broke up and I didn't really want to
have a relationship like that I've seen
you guys still kind of even right after
your breakup news dropped you guys were
like posting on each other's instagrams
so are you talking a lot still and how
are things we talk every few days it's
hard to talk every day
I mean we're we tried our best to keep
it and look cool because we decided to
break up and go through everything first
and then go public so I think in a way
that's helped us to remain friends when
and also we just don't talk bad about
each other I think that's you know look
at the maturity how long were you guys
split up before you did drop the nose
about a month yeah and we were living
together during that time too which is a
little awkward but I feel like it helped
us get everything out of the way so we
had no questions and we would just
agreed like neatly that it was best that
we separated so what takeaways do you
have from your relationship with Joe how
did it change you and what did you learn
from it it taught me how to get there
with somebody in terms of seeing a
marriage with somebody and there's a lot
of really amazing qualities that Joe has
so I'm looking for someone to date in
the future but also taught me a lot of
stuff that I I'm looking at that he
doesn't possess that I'm looking for as
well so if anything it taught me that
I'm capable
like that sort of love like marriage
love so so are you dating now not really
not really I guess I'm open to dating
but it's almost weird to date again
after being in a relationship that
serious so I guess I'm trying to learn
how to date in like this day and age
with like apps and everything I here's
the thing you are this light of a human
being but the sense I am kind of getting
from you right now is you went through
something really hard it sounds like
this breakup really hit you definitely
yeah it was definitely difficult I think
but I think I like to see hope and
happiness in the future where I'm going
to go and I mean as well I think as long
as we both had good intentions for why
it ended I feel like we can kind of move
past that so would you move past it to
paradise again I don't know I mean I
mean honestly there's going to be a lot
more mature men that are going that'll
be kind of an interesting contrast with
you know two different maybe completely
different seasons again Never Say Never
but uh
[Music]